This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. [♪ Music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, and only 200 yards at their narrowest. And there's one part of the outer banks that used to be especially treacherous for ships. It's called Cape Hatteras. That's reported Gordon Catech of a podcast called Cited. The Cape is known for choppy seas and strong ocean currents. Since the 16th century, these waves have caused a lot of shipwrecks, over a thousand, according to the National Park Service. The areas become known as the Graveyard of the Atlantic.
这里是“99%隐形”播客，我是罗曼·马尔斯。外滩群岛最窄的地方只有两百码宽。外滩群岛有一部分过去对船只来说格外危险，叫做哈特拉斯角。播客节目《引用》（Cited）的戈登·卡泰奇报道称，该海角以波涛汹涌和强劲的洋流而闻名。据国家公园管理局称，自16世纪以来，这些巨浪已经造成了大量海难，数量超过一千起。这个地区被称为“大西洋的墓地”。
So many sailors were dying that in the late 1700s, Congress authorized the construction of a giant lighthouse. It would illuminate the dangerous passage and make the outer banks less deadly. The lighthouse went up in a small town called Bucston, North Carolina, right near Cape Hatteras. And the people of Bucston, they love this lighthouse. Generations of families there have helped maintain it. You know, it's what your grandfather did, it's what your great grandfather did.
当时有太多的水手丧生，于是在18世纪末，国会授权建造一座巨大的灯塔。它将照亮这条危险的航道，让外滩群岛变得不那么致命。这座灯塔建在北卡罗来纳州巴克斯顿的一个小镇上，紧邻哈特拉斯角。巴克斯顿的人民非常热爱这座灯塔。那里一代又一代的家庭都协助维护它。你知道的，这是你爷爷做过的事，也是你曾祖父做过的事。
This is Danny Kouch. He's descended from English pirates, and his family goes back nine generations in North Carolina. Today, Danny leads tours of the Outer Banks. Gordon went on one of those tours last summer. But we've got three maritime symbols in this country. Number one, the Statue of Liberty. Number two, the Golden Gate Bridge, and then number three, the Granddaddy of American Lighthouse, the 288th Hall, the 800-inch pine house. After him's on the right,
这是丹尼·库奇。他是英国海盗的后裔，他的家族在北卡罗来纳州可以追溯到九代人。如今，丹尼负责外滩群岛的旅游导览。戈登去年夏天参加了其中一次旅行。“我们在国内有三个海上象征。第一，自由女神像。第二，金门大桥，第三，美国灯塔的老祖宗，288英尺高的、有黑白螺旋条纹的灯塔。”在右手边，
we can leave anything you need on board, we don't have any crying here. Okay. It is pretty majestic. It's got a red base and a really tall, black and white spiralally paint job sort of like a black and white candy cane. I see some people on top. It's a little observation deck. There's a crowd of people waiting outside. A park ranger is standing near the
我们可以把你需要的东西留在船上，我们这里没有哭泣。好吧。它确实非常雄伟。它有着红色的基座，还有非常高、黑白相间的螺旋形油漆，有点像一块黑白相间的拐杖糖。我看到顶上有些人。那是一个小观景台。外面有一群人在排队等候。一名公园管理员正站在
entrance. That's because this is all a national park. This is the tallest brick lighthouse in North America that you all are about to climb today. So hope everybody's ready to climb. It is a strenuous climb today. It's hard to overstate just how important this lighthouse is to the people of Bucston. There are three lighthouse gift shops in town. Practically every business here has a lighthouse in its logo or its name, like the lighthouse view motel, or the lighthouse view motel or the lighthouse
入口附近。那是因为这里整个都是国家公园。这是北美最高的一座砖造灯塔，各位今天就要去攀登它。所以希望大家都准备好去爬山。今天的攀登非常吃力。这座灯塔对巴克斯顿人民有多么重要，是怎么高估都不为过的。镇上有三家灯塔礼品店。这里的几乎每家企业都在其标志或名称中使用灯塔，比如灯塔景观汽车旅馆，或者灯塔景观汽车旅馆，还有
sports bar and grill. Even the churches, like the lighthouse Christian assembly. But back in the 70s, it looked like Bucston might lose their beloved lighthouse. The sea was getting closer and closer, threatening to swallow it up, and people were torn over what to do. Move the lighthouse or leave it in place, and try to defend it against the forces of nature. For the next 30 years, the people of Bucson fought an intense political battle over this decision. It's the kind of battle we can expect to see a lot more of, as sea levels rise and threaten coastal communities around the world. It all started with a scientist who had a radical idea about what to do with the lighthouse.
灯塔运动酒吧烧烤店。甚至连教堂也是如此，比如灯塔基督教会。但在70年代，巴克斯顿似乎有可能失去他们深爱的灯塔。大海离它越来越近，威胁着要将它吞没，人们对该怎么做意见不一。是把灯塔搬走，还是让它留在原地，并试图抵御大自然的力量？在接下来的30年里，巴克斯顿的人民围绕这个决定展开了一场激烈的政治斗争。随着海平面上升并威胁到世界各地的沿海社区，这种斗争是我们预计以后会见得更多的。这一切都始于一位科学家，他对如何处理这座灯塔有着激进的想法。
An idea almost nobody liked. Let it fall into. Nothing is so important that it can't fall into the sea. Why don't you introduce yourself, Lauren? Oh yeah, I'm Lauren Pilke. I'm a retired marine geologist who started out in the deep sea and ended up on the beaches. Lauren Pilke is a professor emeritus at Duke University. He typically wears short sleeve button-up shirts
一个几乎没人喜欢的想法。让它倒塌。没有什么东西重要到不能倒进海里。劳伦，你为什么不自我介绍一下？哦，好的，我是劳伦·皮尔基。我是一名退休的海洋地质学家，最初研究深海，最后研究海滩。劳伦·皮尔基是杜克大学的名誉教授。他通常穿着短袖衬衫，
with two or three pens in the front pocket. And he studies beaches, but there aren't any beaches at Duke because Duke is right in the middle of the state. So in the 1980s, Orn would pack his students into a bus and head east, all the way to the Cape Hatteras lighthouse. It's usually a pretty exciting place. The average wave height at Cape Hatteras is higher than anywhere else on the east coast except possibly northern Maine. Orrin would tell his students that the waves at Cape Hatteras don't just calmly roll onto shore.
前胸口袋里插着两三支笔。他研究海滩，但杜克大学并没有海滩，因为杜克大学位于州的正中心。所以在20世纪80年代，奥林会把学生们塞进一辆巴士，向东进发，一路来到哈特拉斯角灯塔。这里通常是一个非常令人兴奋的地方。除了可能的缅因州北部外，哈特拉斯角的平均浪高比东海岸的其他任何地方都要高。奥林会告诉他的学生，哈特拉斯角的巨浪不仅仅是平静地涌向海岸。
They slam into it and spray up into the air. While the students stared out into the water or unexplained, these waves are washing away the beach we're standing on, and soon they'll reach the lighthouse. The shoreline of the outer bank, the entire shoreline of the outer bank is a roading, and partly this is simply a matter of the waves picking away at the cotton that 90% of the world's beaches are roting. Some very, very slightly and some very quickly. The beach in front of the lighthouse can rot fast. The rates vary wildly from decade to decade. Sometimes the coast loses 50 feet a year.
它们猛烈地撞击海岸并溅起水花。当学生们凝视着水面或惊叹时，这些巨浪正在冲刷我们脚下的海滩，很快它们就会到达灯塔。外滩群岛的海岸线，外滩群岛的整个海岸线都在侵蚀，部分原因很简单，就是海浪侵蚀了世界90%正在侵蚀的海滩。有些非常、非常缓慢，有些则非常快。灯塔前的海滩可能会侵蚀得很快。侵蚀速度在不同十年间差异巨大。有时海岸每年会后退50英尺。
Other times the beach actually gains sand. It's an erratic, natural process. But Warren says climate change is also part of the story. It's speeding up the erosion process. For decades, a bunch of different government agencies have been fighting back against the sea. They tried barriers to slow the waves. They put down a wall of sandbags.
其他时候，海滩实际上会积聚沙子。这是一个不稳定、自然的进程。但奥林说，气候变化也是其中一部分原因。它正在加速侵蚀过程。几十年来，许多不同的政府机构一直在与海洋进行抗争。他们尝试用屏障来减缓海浪。他们堆起了一道沙袋墙。
They even tried this thing called beach nourishment. That's just a fancy way of saying, pumping a ton of sand onto the shore. And they had some other inventive ideas too. They put in what they call seascape. It was plastic strips of plastic that floated. Strips were supposed to act like seaweed and keep the sand from washing away. And here it was. This is a very cheap way to stop erosion the Cape Hattles lighthouse, but it didn't even begin to work. In fact, none of this stuff worked. After decades of fighting back against the waves,
他们甚至尝试了一种叫做海滩养护的东西。这只是一种高级说法，意思就是往海岸上泵送大量的沙子。他们还有一些其他创新的想法。他们安装了他们所说的主题海景（seascape）。那是漂浮的塑料条。这些海绵状的塑料条本应用作海草，防止沙子被冲走。这就是它。这是一种阻止哈特拉斯角灯塔侵蚀的非常便宜的方法，但它根本没有发挥作用。事实上，这些东西全都没用。在与海浪抗争了数十年之后，
the ocean was getting dangerously close to the lighthouse, less than half of a ball field away. Basically, we would stand beside the lighthouse and see how this precious historic structure was due to fall in. I mean it was easy to see where a good storm would have taken out the lighthouse. It wouldn't have to be a whimdener storm but it had gotten to that stage. And so in 1974, Orrin wrote an academic article, he said, we've tried pretty much everything to protect this lighthouse.
海洋已经危险地逼近灯塔，距离不到半个棒球场。基本上，我们就站在灯塔旁边，看着这座珍贵的历史建筑将要倒塌。我的意思是，很容易看出在哪场好风暴中灯塔就会被冲毁。它甚至不需要是一场强烈的风暴，但它已经到了那个阶段。所以在1974年，奥林写了一篇学术文章，他说，我们几乎尝试了一切来保护这座灯塔。
It's time to give up. He wrote, quote, it is difficult, but necessary, to come to grips with the ultimate result of living with nature at the shoreline. And then he started telling the people of Bucston to let the lighthouse go. Which made them really mad. The whole idea of letting things fall in
是时候放弃了。他写道：“与海岸线上的大自然共处，其最终结果虽然难以接受，但却是必须面对的。”然后他开始告诉巴克斯顿的人民，放手让灯塔倒掉吧。这让他们非常生气。让东西倒塌的整个想法
was absolutely outrageous. Of course we're going to defend ourselves. As one core of engineered colonels said, we're not just going to hold up our hands and slink away. Most North Carolinians did not want to see the lighthouse fall into the sea. In 1981, a photographer and conservationist named Hugh Morton started a group called Save the Lighthouse.
简直太荒谬了。我们当然要捍卫自己。正如一位陆军工程兵团的陆军上校所说：“我们不会只是举起双手灰溜溜地逃走。”大多数北卡罗来纳州人不希望看到灯塔落入大海。1981年，一位名叫休·莫顿的摄影师兼环保主义者发起了一个名为“拯救灯塔”的组织。
School children across the state raised money to support the group. And they recruited prominent North Carolinians, like university presidents, business leaders, and politicians. Danny, the tour guide from the beginning of the story, he became the local representative for Save the Lighthouse. In terms of uniting political philosophies and contradictory elements of society,
全州各地的学童筹集资金支持该组织。他们招募了北卡罗来纳州的知名人士，如大学校长、商界领袖和政治家。故事开始时的导游丹尼，成为了“拯救灯塔”组织的地方代表。在团结政治哲学和社会中相互矛盾的元素方面，
developers, and environmentalists, everybody can rally around the Cape Atters lighthouse. And that was essentially the essence of what was going on. Nothing else mattered. It was to do right by that lighthouse in our heritage in this country. Eventually Danny settles on one big idea. Build a solid concrete wall all the way around the lighthouse. I think you can pick and choose your fights with Mother Nature. You're not going to win all of them. You got to pick a fight that you can win. Ah, yes.
开发商和环保主义者，每个人都可以围绕哈特拉斯角灯塔团结起来。这基本上就是当时正在发生的事情的本质。其他一切都不重要。重要的是为这座灯塔以及我们在这个国家的文化遗产做正确的事。最终，丹尼确定了一个重大想法。在灯塔周围建造一圈坚固的混凝土墙。我认为你可以选择与大自然母亲的战斗。你不可能赢得所有战斗。你必须挑选一场你能打赢的战斗。啊，是的。
That was a very common attitude in those days, but my idea was to live with nature at the shoreline. Orren thought the sea wall would be extremely expensive and ultimately counterproductive. Well, sea walls, this is one of the more controversial things that I would think others too, that sea walls destroy beaches. Orren had maps and diagrams of the East Coast, and they showed that seawalls made erosion happen even faster. He argued that that's exactly what would happen at the lighthouse.
那是当时非常普遍的态度，但我的想法是与海岸线上的自然和谐相处。奥林认为海堤会非常昂贵，而且最终会适得其反。嗯，海堤，这是我想要提出的更具争议的事情之一，即海堤会破坏海滩。奥林有东海岸的地图和图表，它们显示海堤会使侵蚀发生得更快。他认为这正是灯塔会发生的情况。
A wall would make the beach smaller and smaller. So now you're a beach community without a beach? With this seawall plan, the lighthouse would eventually become a walled island out in the water. Not ideal, but even if you were fine with that, the wall probably wouldn't hold. Orin said it's hard to imagine building a sea wall strong enough for the waves at Cape Hatteras. They have lots of big storms at the Cape, unless the sea wall is going to be half the size
一堵墙会使海滩变得越来越小。所以现在你是一个没有海滩的沿海社区？有了这个海堤计划，灯塔最终将变成水中的一个筑墙小岛。这并不理想，但即使你对此没有异议，这堵墙也可能撑不住。奥林说，很难想象能建造一座足够坚强、抵御哈特拉斯角海浪的海堤。海角有很多大风暴，除非海堤建得有
of the lighthouse, the storm surge would top over the sea wall and top of the lighthouse. Then one day, Orin met an engineer named Dave Feshetti. Dave said, look, people don't want the lighthouse to fall in. We don't want a sea wall, but there's a compromise. That thing can be moved. It's around 200 feet tall, about 1.25 million bricks and 48 hundred tons, but believe it or not, engineers have moved bigger buildings. This presented a pretty good opportunity for Orin. He could use the lighthouse to test something that planners call Managed Retreat. The idea is that, as sea levels rise, we won't be able to defend every coast with a giant wall.
灯塔一半大小，否则风暴潮会漫过海堤和灯塔顶部。后来有一天，奥林遇到了一位名叫戴夫·费谢蒂的工程师。戴夫说，听着，人们不想让灯塔倒塌。我们不想要海堤，但有一个折中的办法。那东西可以移动。它大约有200英尺高，大约125万块砖，重4800吨，但信不信由你，工程师们移动过更大的建筑物。这为奥林提供了一个绝佳的机会。他可以利用这座灯塔来测试规划人员所称的“有计划的退让”。这个想法是，随着海平面上升，我们将无法用巨大的墙来保卫每一处海岸。
Instead, we're going to have to make plans to abandon certain areas and move some things out of the way. Orren thought, if Bucston could be convinced to move this big lighthouse, it might show that managed retreat is doable. So he and Dave Feshaddy, along with one of Or of Orange students, Dave Bush, formed their own group. They called themselves the Move the Lighthouse Committee. We met together a lot and we produced a blizzard of papers documenting things about erosion and things about moving buildings and mainly aimed at the media. So why did you care so much to spend so much your time? Yeah, well, it became a challenge, of course.
相反，我们必须制定计划，放弃某些地区，把一些东西移开。奥林想，如果能说服巴克斯顿移动这座巨大的灯塔，这或许能证明有计划的退让是可行的。于是他与戴夫·费谢蒂，以及奥林的学生之一戴夫·布什，成立了自己的组织。他们自称为“移动灯塔委员会”。我们经常聚在一起，炮制了大量的文件，记录了有关侵蚀和移动建筑的事情，主要针对媒体。那你为什么如此关心并花那么多时间呢？是的，嗯，这成了一种挑战，当然。
It became a, I guess I got emotionally involved also. I wasn't going to let that lighthouse fall in, and it's by the first article of mine. So now you got these two groups. They both want to preserve the lighthouse, but they're debating how. Ultimately, it's up to Congress and the National Park Service because this is federal property. So the two groups are trying to convince the feds that they have the better plan.
这成了一种，我想我也在情感上卷入了其中。我不会让那座灯塔倒塌，这是我的第一篇文章。现在你有这两个组织。他们都想保护灯塔，但他们在争论如何保护。归根结底，这要由国会和国家公园管理局决定，因为这是联邦财产。所以这两个组织正试图说服联邦官员，他们有更好的计划。
The town of Bucston flatly rejected Orren's move idea. A local magazine did a poll, over 90% of residents wanted to keep the lighthouse in place. Many were offended by the very idea of retreat. Hugh Morton said retreating from the shoreline would be, quote, seeding man's historic battle against nature. And it would make Buckston the laughing stock of the coast. Danny's group, that saved the lighthouse. They felt confident they could win this fight.
巴克斯顿镇断然拒绝了奥林搬迁灯塔的想法。当地一家杂志做了一项民意调查，超过90%的居民希望将灯塔留在原地。许多人被退让的想法本身所冒犯。休·莫顿说，从海岸线撤退将是“拱手相让人类与自然历史性战斗的成果”。这将使巴克斯顿成为海岸上的笑柄。丹尼的组织，即“拯救灯塔”组织。他们对赢得这场战斗充满信心。
And they didn't like these outsiders telling them otherwise. It was a situation of, you know, again, where the local people kind of claim ownership of that. And how dare somebody with some out of state plates come in here and want to tell these poor dwellers on these shifting lonely sands what to do with their lighthouse? I mean, we're not afraid to pick a fight. We're very independent people.
他们不喜欢这些外地人告诉他们该怎么做。这是一种情况，你知道的，当地人再次宣称对那里拥有所有权。一个拿着外州车牌的人怎么敢来这里，告诉这些在不断变化的孤独沙滩上的可怜居民该如何处理他们的灯塔？我的意思是，我们不怕挑起争端。我们是非常独立的人。
Danny told me a story to explain the tension between Orn's group and the locals. He said there was a Duke grad student who would drive down to give talks in Bucston. Danny remembered meeting him one day. And he proceeded to Waltson to a gas station that I was running at the time, Phil and station automotive repair shop. And we're changing out semi-tires for tractor trailers and stuff and he starts wagging his finger, and he'll figure my face.
丹尼给我讲了一个故事，以解释奥林团队与当地人之间的紧张关系。他说，曾有一名杜克大学的研究生开车到巴克斯顿发表演讲。丹尼记得有一天遇见了他。他径直走进我当时经营的一家加油站，菲尔加油汽车修理厂。当时我们正在为半挂车和类似车辆更换半挂轮胎，他开始摇晃着手指，指着我的脸。
Don't you know that this lighthouse, we're gonna lose this lighthouse, and y'all are obstruction as y'all are. You are not y'all, he didn't, he wasn't a y'all. He said, you are holding this up, you're holding this project up. And I'm standing there with like a tire arm in my hand. Orin and his group had a serious credibility problem in Bucston.
难道你不知道这座灯塔，我们要失去这座灯塔了吗，你们这些阻挠者。你们不是“你们”，他不是用的“你们”。他说：“你们在阻挠这个，你们在阻挠这个项目。”而我手里正拿着一个轮胎撬棒站在那里。奥林和他的团队在巴克斯顿遭遇了严重的信誉危机。
And they understood why people like Danny were upset. Of course, of course we were outside and we were from way far away in Durham. Did this ever give you pause? I suppose so. Going into the community and saying, hey, I know the truth. And I felt that there was a bit of arrogance in that, but what was the choice?
他们理解为什么像丹尼这样的人会生 气。当然，当然，我们是外地人，我们来自遥远的达勒姆。这曾让你犹豫过吗？我想是的。进入一个社区说：“嘿，我知道真相。”我觉得这里面有点傲慢，但又有什么选择呢？
I didn't know anything about how you deal with people, I guess, in this sense. I understood sometimes that I was speaking over their head. They're saying things that they did not understand or didn't want to understand. And there were other reasons people didn't like Orn's group. Many word the lighthouse was so big and so old that it would break if you tried to move it. Others had strong feelings about the location of the Lighthouse. They said it would lose historical value in a new spot.
我想在这种意义上，我根本不懂如何与人打交道。有时我明白自己的话超出了他们的理解能力。他们说的话是他们不理解或不想理解的。人们不喜欢奥林的团队还有其他原因。许多人担心灯塔又大又老，如果试图移动它，它会散架。其他人对灯塔的位置有着强烈的感情。他们说它在一个新地点会失去历史价值。
And then there were also some big money interests. Business owners and real estate developers thought a move would hurt their bottom line. If you own something with a name like the Lighthouse View Motel and then people move the Lighthouse out of of you. You can see the problem. Throughout the 80s and 90s, there were lots of scientific committees, commissions, studies and reports. They all decided that moving the lighthouse was the best idea, but that didn't do much to convince the locals. Except for these two local lighthouse historians, Bruce and Cheryl Roberts.
还有一些巨大利益集团。企业主和房地产开发商认为，搬迁会损害他们的底线。如果你经营着一家名字叫“灯塔景观汽车旅馆”之类的地方，然后人们把灯塔移出了你的视野。你可以看到问题所在。在整个80和90年代，有许多科学委员会、委员会、研究和报告。他们都认为搬迁灯塔是最好的主意，但这并没有对说服当地人起太大作用。除了这两位当地的灯塔历史学家，布鲁斯和谢丽尔·罗伯茨。
Bruce, nice to meet you. Yeah, how you doing? You? Come on in. Nice to meet you. Yeah. How you doing? You're right on time? Yeah. Cheryl wasn't around when I met Bruce. She was busy working on a new lighthouse book. My wife does most of the routing and I take pictures of lighthouses.
布鲁斯，很高兴认识你。对，你好吗？你？请进。很高兴认识你。对。你好吗？你准时到了吗？对。我见到布鲁斯时，谢丽尔不在。她正忙着写一本新的灯塔书。我妻子负责大部分写作，我负责拍摄灯塔。
I've actually photographed almost every American lighthouse. Bruce and Cheryl have basically turned their home into a shrine for lighthouses. They've got over a hundred lighthouse books. There's a bunch of miniature lighthouses scattered about. I see countless lighthouse paintings and pictures. And in their study, there's a giant three-panel room divider. It looks like one of those Japanese screens. Only it's got the Cape Hatteras lighthouse painted on it.
我实际上拍摄了几乎每一座美国灯塔。布鲁斯和谢丽尔基本上把他们的家变成了一个灯塔圣殿。他们有一百多本灯塔书。周围散落着一堆微型灯塔。我看到无数的灯塔画作和图片。在他们的书房里，有一个巨大的三扇屏风隔断。它看起来像那些日本屏风之一。只是上面画着哈特拉斯角灯塔。
There is something about a lighthouse I think that is special. And particularly Hatteras, it's the best, best known one. Back at the time of the controversy, Bruce and Cheryl were writing a book about the Cape Hatteras Lighthouse. That's when they started to do some research. We had read the reports that the lighthouse would be lost and we talked to some of the scientists who had studied this and made an interesting discovery. The scientists told them that the lighthouse sits on yellow pine timbers. They're submerged in a pool of freshwater. It's a strange design. The builder who constructed the lighthouse
我想灯塔总有某种特别之处。尤其是哈特拉斯，它是最好、最著名的灯塔。在争议发生的时候，布鲁斯和谢丽尔正在写一本关于哈特拉斯角灯塔的书。正是在那时，他们开始做一些研究。我们读过关于灯塔将不保的报告，我们与一些研究过此事的科学家进行了交谈，并有了一个有趣的发现。科学家告诉他们，灯塔建在黄松木原木上。它们浸没在淡水池中。这是一个奇怪的设计。建造灯塔的建造者
knew that if he kept those beams in fresh water, they'd be preserved. And his plan had worked for over a hundred years. But here's the problem. The ocean was coming closer and closer to the lighthouse. And the ocean is filled with microorganisms that could degrade the wood. If the saltwater seeped into the foundation, the beams would rot. And that was the reason that Cheryl and I realized that if nothing else happened, a lighthouse
知道，如果他把这些木梁泡在淡水中，它们就会得到保存。他的计划已经奏效了一百多年。但问题来了。海洋离灯塔越来越近了。而海洋中充满了会降解木材的微生物。如果盐水渗入地基，木梁就会腐烂。这就是谢丽尔和我意识到，如果什么都不做，灯塔
would begin to tip as that wood foundation was eaten away. We actually went and talked to several of the scientists who had signed the study saying it had to be moved. And we got convinced that they knew what they were doing, and that it could be done. This was a huge get for team move the lighthouse. Bruce and Cheryl weren't technocratic outsiders. They were lighthouse fanatics and they were saying, look, like it or not, the scientists are actually right.
会开始倾斜，因为木质地基已经被侵蚀掉了。我们实际上去和几位签署了必须搬迁研究报告的科学家交谈过。我们确信他们知道自己在做什么，而且这是可以做到的。这对“移动灯塔”团队来说是一个巨大的收获。布鲁斯和谢丽尔不是技术官僚式的局外人。他们是灯塔狂热分子，他们说，听着，不管你喜欢与否，科学家们其实是对的。
Then in 1996, two major hurricanes hit North Carolina. Hurricane Broughan and Hurricane Fran. North Carolina and the Okra-Koke Island and Hatteras Island are under an evacuation mandate. With the waves counting on the dunes, they likely won't be much peace near tomorrow. Hurricanes were becoming more frequent and more intense, and this created a new sense of urgency. So in 1997, Congress started planning a potential move. 17 years after Save the Lighthouse formed, and after almost two decades of debate,
然后在1996年，两场大型飓风袭击了北卡罗来纳州。伯莎飓风和弗兰飓风。北卡罗来纳州以及奥克拉科克岛和哈特拉斯岛都处于疏散令之下。随着巨浪拍击沙丘，明天附近可能不会有多少平静。飓风变得更加频繁和强烈，这产生了一种新的紧迫感。于是在1997年，国会开始规划一次潜在的搬迁。在“拯救灯塔”成立17年后，经过近二十年的争论，
a public meeting was held to discuss the move. It was organized by a US Senator from North Carolina, as well as a state Senator from the region. It was April 1998, about 400 people filed into an aquarium, the largest building in the outer banks. Children were bust in from every school. There were 11 news crews there reporting on the event.
举行了一场公开会议来讨论搬迁事宜。会议由来自北卡罗来纳州的美国参议员以及该地区的州参议员组织。那是1998年4月，大约400人涌入一个水族馆，这是外滩群岛最大的建筑。孩子们从各个学校乘大巴被送来。现场有11个新闻摄制组报道这一事件。
The people of Bucston knew the fate of the lighthouse might be decided here, today. They had their move it or lose it's signs. And then the others were like, save, not move. This guy came up to me, grabbed me by the arm, said, here's your sticker. And I looked at it and said, move it or lose it's signs and then the others were like, save, not move. This guy came up to me, grabbed me by the arm, and said, here's your sticker. And I looked at it and said, move it or lose it. I don't want that damn sticker.
巴克斯顿的人民知道，灯塔的命运可能今天就会在这里决定。他们手里拿着“不搬就倒”的标语。然后其他人则喊着“保存，不要搬”。这个家伙走到我跟前，抓住我的胳膊，说，这是你的贴纸。我看了看，说：“不搬就倒”的标语。然后其他人则喊着“保存，不要搬”。这个家伙走到我跟前，抓着我的胳膊，说：“这是你的贴纸。我看了看，说：”不搬就倒。”我才不要那该死的贴纸。
Politicians and their aides watched as people got up to testify for each side. Every time somebody said something that was beneficial to their side, they would erupt in cheers like you or some of the Roman Coliseum with a bunch of gladiators. And Bruce, who was there along with Danny, thought the crowd was clearly against the lighthouse move. I think I felt that we were going to lose.
政客和他们的助手们看着人们上台为各自的立场作证。每当有人说出对他们有利的话时，他们就会爆发出欢呼声，就像你身处罗马斗士竞技场面对一群角斗士一样。和丹尼一起出席的布鲁斯认为，人群明显反对搬迁灯塔。我想我觉得我们要输了。
Bruce went back home feeling defeated. He was convinced Congress was not going to fund the move. I think that that day or two, I heard the phone ringing back in the office in Cheryl. Went back and I heard her say, oh yes, Senator. North Carolina State Senator Mark Bassnight was on the other end of the phone. He said, before the meeting I supported moving the the lighthouse but then i saw just how unpopular that was and now i don't think i can do it and i said wait a minute here's sharel
布鲁斯带着失败感回到了家。他确信国会将不会资助这次搬迁。我想就在那天或第二天，我听到办公室里的电话在响，是谢丽尔。走回去，我听到她说：“哦，是的，参议员。”北卡罗来纳州参议员马克·巴斯奈特在电话的那头。他说：“会议之前我支持搬迁灯塔，但我随后看到那是多么不受欢迎，现在我认为我做不到这一点。”我说：“等一下，这里有谢丽尔，
you know about that timber that's the foundation and the danger of it's collapsing he said no i said well the mart of its collapsing. He said, no. I said, well, then, Mark, you should not be making a decision in this matter. You need to listen more to the facts." Cheryl told the senator about the pine boards in the saltwater. She told him, if we don't move it, the lighthouse might just fall over. And he's listened to her an hour and a half. And she won him over.
你知道关于那块作为地基的木头以及它倒塌的危险吗？”他说：“没有。”我说：“好吧，马克，你不应该在这个问题上做出决定。你需要多听听事实。”谢丽尔向参议员讲述了盐水中的松木板。她告诉他，如果我们不搬迁，灯塔可能就会倒塌。他听她讲了一个半小时。她赢得了他的支持。
His eyes had to be open. He had to know the facts, the scientific facts. This was the critical moment. Cheryl got the senator back on board, and he urged Congress to act fast. A few months later, Congress funded the move. In a last-titch effort, the local county sued, but they lost. It was a stinging reminder that even though it may have felt like Buston's lighthouse, it wasn't. It belonged to the federal government. It's an exciting morning here. We're live at Cape
他的眼睛必须睁开。他必须知道事实，科学的事实。这是关键时刻。谢丽尔重新争取到了参议员的支持，他敦促国会迅速采取行动。几个月后，国会为搬迁提供资金。在最后关头，当地县政府提起诉讼，但他们输了。这是一个痛苦的提醒，尽管它可能让人感觉是巴克斯顿的灯塔，但并不是。它属于联邦政府。这里是一个令人兴奋的早晨。我们在哈特拉斯角进行现场直播，
Hatteras, and we're going to have all sorts of folks to talk to you. The moon began on June 17, 1999, over 200 journalists swarmed Bucston. Because nothing like this had ever happened before, no one had picked up a 4,800 ton lighthouse and moved it over half a mile. People called it the Move of the millennia. Make sure they know we're rolling the tape from the truck. You're hearing tape from a documentary made by a local TV station. Already there have been 1800 visitors to the park this morning.
我们将邀请各种各样的人来和大家交谈。搬迁于1999年6月17日开始，200多名记者蜂拥至巴克斯顿。因为以前从未发生过这样的事，没有人拿起过一座4800吨重的灯塔并把它移动半英里以上。人们称之为“千禧年大搬迁”。确保他们知道我们正在用卡车滚动磁带。你听到的是当地电视台制作的纪录片中的录音。今天早上公园已经迎来了1800名游客。
That's about double what they usually see coming here this time of year. The park service put an orange fence near the base of the lighthouse, and tourists lined up along it. Locals sold them t-shirts and hot dogs as everyone waited anxiously. Brian, what do you think about the lighthouse? What do you think about it? What? It's so big. Unweighted anxiously. Brian, what do you think about the lighthouse? What do you think about it? It's so big. It sure is big.
这大约是他们平时一年中这个时候看到的人数的两倍。公园管理局在灯塔底部附近设置了一道橙色栅栏，游客们顺着栅栏排起了长队。当地人在焦急等待的同时向他们出售T恤和热狗。布赖恩，你觉得灯塔怎么样？你觉得它怎么样？什么？它太大了。在焦急等待的同时。布赖恩，你觉得灯塔怎么样？你觉得它怎么样？什么？它太大了。它确实很大。
How are they going to move that? Can they pick it up? I'm sorry, but it's heavy. It is heavy. The process was pretty simple. First, the engineers cut through the granite base of the lighthouse. Then they slid seven giant steel beams underneath it.
他们要怎么搬走那个？他们能把它抬起来吗？我很抱歉，但它很重。它确实很重。整个过程非常简单。首先，工程师们切开灯塔的花岗岩基座。然后，他们在它下面滑入了七根巨大的钢梁。
The beams created a new foundation, a grid under the lighthouse. Open your number one. Pressure at 44. Then they rolled wheels under the steel grid, and using hydraulics, they lifted the whole thing up onto a track leading to the lighthouse's new home. Pull the swatz now, up we go. Alright, coming up. up onto a track leading to the lighthouse's new home. The engineers were already to roll. They pulled a giant lever and the lighthouse started to inch forward.
这些钢梁在灯塔下方创造了一个新的地基，一个网格。打开一号。压力44。然后，他们在钢梁网格下滚动轮子，利用液压装置，把整个东西抬起到通往灯塔新家的轨道上。现在拉动开关，我们上吧。好的，上来。通往灯塔新家的轨道上。工程师们已经准备好滚动了。他们拉动了一个巨大的杠杆，灯塔开始向前挪动。
If you were there that day in the crowd, this all would have looked anti-comacted because the lighthouse moved so slow. You couldn't even tell. The Rangers had to put markers along the track just so you could be sure that it did in fact move. It's just going real, real slow. Yeah, nice. It's cool. And you're lucky to be here to see it. At the end of the first day, the lighthouse
如果你那天身在人群中，这一切看起来都会毫无波澜，因为灯塔移动得太慢了。你甚至看不出来。护林员不得不在轨道沿线设置标记，好让你确信它确实移动了。它只是走得非常、非常慢。是的，很好。这很酷。你很幸运能在这里看到它。第一天结束时，灯塔
had only moved 10 feet. This whole process would take weeks. Oh, my word. It still going up. Slowly, but surely. Bruce remembers showing up one day near the end of the move. He saw Danny coming towards him through the crowd.
只移动了10英尺。整个过程需要数周时间。天哪。它还在往上走。虽慢但稳。布鲁斯记得在搬迁快结束时有一天出现在现场。他看到丹尼穿过人群向他走来。
Danny told him they're moving it too fast. I'm stunned. I said, what's wrong with moving it too fast? He says, look, every restaurant is making money. Every hotel is making money. We have never had crowds like this ever before. And you said, if you can just slow it down until September, we'll all be rich. Slow it down, slow it a half, 1 inch. Hey, that's it, Ben.
丹尼告诉他，他们搬得太快了。我惊呆了。我说，搬得太快有什么不对？他说，听着，每家餐馆都在赚钱。每家酒店都在赚钱。我们从来没有见过这样的人潮。你说：“如果你能把它放慢到九月，我们都会发财。”慢下来，慢半英寸。嘿，就是这样，本。
Right there. That's it. As the lighthouse inched to its new home, it was again 1,600 feet from shore. The exact same distance it was in 1870 before the sea washed the beach away. Before the move, the people of Bucston felt something terrible and undemocratic was happening to them. These out of towners were destroying the heart and soul of their island.
就在那儿。就是这样。当灯塔缓慢挪向它的新家时，它再次距离海岸1,600英尺。这与1870年海水冲毁海滩之前的距离完全一样。搬迁之前，巴克斯顿的人民觉得有什么可怕且不民主的事情正在他们身上发生。这些外地人正在摧毁他们岛屿的心脏和灵魂。
The community fought hard, and they lost. But in a strange way, things actually worked out for them. I look back at this, you know, after this is all said and done, was moving that lighthouse the right thing to do? Yes it was. Danny got a ton of business from the tourists. His repair shop and gas station had never done so well. So he's had a complete change of heart, and he's not alone.
这个社区进行了激烈的抗争，但他们输了。但在某种奇怪的情况下，事情对他们来说确实迎刃而解了。我回想起这件事，你知道的，在这这一切尘埃落定之后，搬迁灯塔是正确的做法吗？是的，确实如此。丹尼从游客那里获得了大量生意。他的修理厂和加油站生意从未这么好过。所以他的想法发生了彻底的转变，而且他并不孤单。
In fact, most people think that the move was the best thing that ever happened to Bucston. Something as monumental as moving America's lighthouse put us on a national radar, on an international radar, and people started thinking about the outer banks. It was a raging success. Danny doesn't look back now and see the move as a cowardly retreat. He sees it as a testament to human ingenuity. This all makes Orin hopeful because if Danny can change his views, maybe others will too. I think the moving the lighthouse was a profound event in terms of our response to sea level ride.
事实上，大多数人认为搬迁是发生在这个巴克斯顿身上最好的事情。像移动美国灯塔这样具有划时代意义的事情，把我们推上了国家雷达，国际雷达，人们开始关注外滩群岛。这是一次巨大的成功。丹尼现在回首往事，不再认为这次搬迁是懦弱的退缩。他将其视为人类智慧的证明。这一切让奥林充满希望，因为如果丹尼能改变他的观点，也许其他人也会。我认为搬迁灯塔是我们应对海平面上升的一个意义重大的事件。
I think the Cape Hatties lighthouse is a good example of What we're going to be doing a lot in the future, if you can move with 3,000 or whatever, just a ton of lighthouse, you can move a lot of colleges. But it's not just lighthouses and beach cottages. There are thousands of miles of vulnerable U.S. coastline. The Battle of Bucksson is just a preview of the tough choices we'll have to make. We have 3,000 miles of barrier on a shoreline, so whatever happens here is also happening in Galveston,
我认为哈特拉斯角灯塔是我们将要在未来大量做的事情的一个好例子，如果你能移动一个3,000吨或无论多少吨重的灯塔，你就能移动很多村舍。但不仅仅是灯塔和海滩村舍。美国有数千英里脆弱的海岸线。巴克斯顿之战只是我们将要面临艰难抉择的一个预演。我们有三千英里的障碍海岸线，所以这里发生的事情也正在加尔维斯顿发生，
and also it's happening in Middle Beach and in Jekyll Island, Georgia, and they're all going to be asking for money from the feds. We need money, we need money, we need to nourish the beach, and we need help buildingish the beach, we need help building a sea wall, but it ain't gotta be there. That's why retreat is important. By the year 2100, at least 500 U.S. communities will be at risk from sea level rise, including major cities like Miami and New Orleans, that's according to the Union of Concerned Scientists. And then there's the millions of people in other parts of the world,
并且它也正在美乐海滩和佐治亚州的哲基尔岛发生，他们都将向联邦政府要钱。我们需要钱，我们需要钱，我们需要养护海滩，我们需要帮助建立海滩，我们需要帮助建立海堤，但它不可能永远呆在那里。这就是为什么退让很重要的原因。到2100年，至少有500个美国社区将面临海平面上升的风险，包括迈阿密和新奥尔良等主要城市，这是根据忧思科学家联盟的数据。还有世界其他地方的数百万民众，
in countries like Bangladesh or the Solomon Islands, that are already being badly affected. If people get this worked up about a lighthouse, imagine how hard it'll be when we start talking about moving entire cities. How can you do that fairly? And in a way that doesn't devastate communities. We're going to be fighting this battle over and over again. And after all of this, the Cape Hatteras Lighthouse will probably have to move again.
在孟加拉国或所罗门群岛等国家，已经受到了严重影响。如果人们对一座灯塔如此大动干戈，想象一下当我们开始讨论搬迁整座城市时会有多难。你该如何公正地做到这一点？并且以一种不会摧毁社区的方式。我们将一遍又一遍地进行这场战斗。而在这一切之后，哈特拉斯角灯塔可能不得不再次搬迁。
It might last 100 years at its current location, but some scientists say it could be even less than that. We have another high-stake story of a building being moved at this time. All the people were in it when it happened. Right after this. Sometimes moving a building is about preserving historic architecture or cultural heritage, but a 99-Pi fan named Tamara Solorzano wrote us about an unusually high stakes move that happened in her hometown of Guadalajara, Mexico.
它在当前的位置可能会维持100年，但一些科学家说甚至可能更短。我们还有另一个高风险的建筑搬迁故事，这次搬迁时所有人都还在里面。就在这之后。有时候，移动一座建筑是为了保护历史建筑或文化遗产，但一位名叫塔玛拉·索洛扎诺的“99-Pi”粉丝写信给我们，讲述了在她家乡墨西哥瓜达拉哈拉发生的一次风险异常高的搬迁。
And Krokosta is here to tell us about it. So back in 1950, city officials in Guadalajara decided to widen a major avenue to accommodate more traffic. And a lot of buildings were just demolished, to make way. But there is a problem. There's this 1, 1700 ton brick structure occupied by the Mexican telephone and telegraph company. Even though the old telephonic and telegraph company
克罗科斯塔在这里为我们讲述这个故事。早在1950年，瓜达拉哈拉的城市官员决定拓宽一条主要大道以容纳更多交通。许多建筑物就这样被拆毁，以为其让路。但有一个问题。这是一座重达1700吨的砖砌建筑，由墨西哥电话电报公司占用。尽管旧的电话电报公司
was the first to be demolished, so why not demolish this building along with the rest of the buildings they demolished when they widen the street? Well, it would have been more expensive, but it also would have knocked out regional telephone service for at least a week. Okay. And that's where Jorge Matute Ramos comes in. He's the civil engineer and he's the dean of the cities university and he has this idea to move the building while leaving everything wired up and keeping the operators at work inside it. Wow. Well, that was to make them pretty nervous.
是第一个被拆毁的，所以为什么不把这座建筑和他们在拓宽街道时拆毁的其他建筑一起拆掉呢？嗯，这会更昂贵，但也会导致区域电话服务中断至少一周。好的。这就是豪尔赫·马图特·拉莫斯登场的时候。他是一名土木工程师，也是该市大学的院长，他有一个主意，在搬迁建筑的同时保持所有线路连通，并让操作员在里面继续工作。哇。嗯，这会让他们相当紧张。
Well, yeah, and Matuti Ramos was definitely sympathetic to that, and he wanted to reassure the operators and make them feel safe. So his wife, Esbaralda, agreed to also go into the building while it was being moved. And she even took along their seven-year-old son, Juan Jorge. And Matuti Ramos has since passed on, but here's this lovely clip of his widow talking about the move on television news. And so,
嗯，是的，马图蒂·拉莫斯对这一点绝对深表同情，他想让操作员放心，让他们感到安全。因此他的妻子埃斯佩拉尔达同意在建筑搬迁时也进去。她甚至带上了他们七岁的儿子胡安·豪尔赫。马图蒂·拉莫斯后来去世了，但这里有一段他遗孀在电视新闻上谈论这次搬迁的可爱视频。所以，
we met Jorge and I, my son, to be very confident. And we all felt the slightest movement. So she says, she and her son, Juanay, were inside the building to gain their trust. And they didn't even feel the tiniest movement when they moved the whole building and all the operators inside it. That's so cool. Yeah.
我们遇到了豪尔赫和我，我的儿子，非常自信。我们都感觉到了最轻微的运动。所以她说，她和她的儿子胡安·内伊在建筑物内部是为了赢得他们的信任。当他们移动整栋建筑以及里面的所有操作员时，他们甚至没有感觉到最微小的运动。太酷了。是的。
And so basically, it all went really well. The building was slowly shifted about 40 feet to its new location. And yeah, the people inside didn't feel a thing. They kept working. And the whole move was done in just five days with no interruption to phone service, very critical. And they did it on a budget of around $100,000, which was a fraction of what it would have cost to demolish the structure and then build some replacement.
基本上，一切都非常顺利。这栋建筑被缓缓平移了大约40英尺来到了新位置。而且，里面的人们一点感觉都没有。他们一直在工作。整个搬迁过程仅用短短五天就完成了，电话服务没有任何中断，这非常关键。他们的预算大约是10万美元，这只占拆除旧建筑再建造新建筑成本的一小部分。
Wow. And so this was about, how long ago about? About 70 years ago. 70 years ago, okay. And so the building, is it still there? Is it along this new widened road? It is. And Matute Ramos has a pretty unique memorial statue
哇。那么这大约是多久以前的事？大约70年前。70年前，好的。那这栋建筑现在还在吗？它还在那条拓宽的新路边吗？是的。而且马图特·拉莫斯有一座相当独特的纪念雕像
right outside the building. It's this life-sized figure of him. And they actually positioned it, so it looks like he's physically pushing the structure by hand. That's so cool. Yeah, next to that sculpture, of course, there's a plaque dedicated to his civil service and engineering genius. Oh, that's fantastic.
就在大楼外面。这是一个与真人大小相仿的他的雕像。他们的摆放位置很巧妙，看起来就像是他正亲手推着这座建筑。太酷了。是的，在那个雕塑旁，当然还有一块献给他的公共服务和工程天才的牌匾。哦，太棒了。
Yeah, it really is. And special thanks to tomorrow for sending that into us to a really neat story. And you can see a video of the move and images of that cool statue of Matute Ray Moose on our website. It's 99pi.org. 99% invisible was produced this week by Gordon Catech and Sam Fen of CIDD podcast, that's C-I-T-E-D like an academic citation. It do stories about research and higher education. You can find their work at CIDDD podcast.com. Social thanks to Mike Boer, Phil Evans, and Stavros Avramides.
是的，确实如此。特别感谢tomorrow将这个故事发给我们，真是一个非常有趣的故事。你可以在我们的网站上看到搬迁的视频以及马图特·拉莫斯那座酷炫雕像的照片。网址是99pi.org。《99%隐形》本周由CIDD播客的戈登·卡特克和萨姆·芬制作，CIDD的拼写是C-I-T-E-D，就像学术引用一样。他们制作关于研究和高等教育的故事。你可以在CIDDpodcast.com找到他们的作品。特别感谢迈克·博尔、菲尔·埃文斯和斯塔夫罗斯·阿夫拉米德斯。
Thanks also to WRAL-TV for letting us use their documentary, The Cape Light, away from the edge. You can find a link to the full program on our website. From our staff, this piece was produced and edited by Delaney Hall, Mixed in Tech Production by Sharif Yusuf, Music by Sean Riel. Katie Mingle is our senior producer, Kurt Kohlsted, is the digital director.
还要感谢WRAL-TV让我们使用他们的纪录片《海角之光：远离边缘》。你可以在我们的网站上找到完整节目的链接。本期节目由我们的员工德兰妮·霍尔制作和剪辑，谢里夫·优素福进行技术混音，肖恩·里尔配乐。凯蒂·明格尔是我们的资深制作人，库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监。
The rest of staff includes Avery Trophiman, Emmith Fitzgerald, Taren Mazza, and me, Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 K.A.L.W. in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown, Oakland, California. We are a part of Radio Topia from PRX, a collective of the best, most innovative shows in all of podcasting. We are supported by of Radio Topia from PRX, a collective of the best, most innovative shows in all of podcasting.
其他员工包括埃弗里·特罗菲曼、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、塔伦·马扎，还有我，罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW电台的一个项目，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心电台街制作。我们是PRX旗下Radiotopia的一部分，这是一个汇集了播客界最好、最具创新性的节目的联盟。我们由PRX旗下Radiotopia支持，这是一个汇集了播客界最好、最具创新性的节目的联盟。
We are supported by listeners just like you, and if you support us in the last drive, well, you should be checking your mailboxes. These are exciting times. You can find 99% invisible and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI or work, or on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. We have more visual design stories and videos too at 99PI.org. Radio Tapio. From PRX.
我们得到像你这样的听众的支持，如果你在上次筹款活动中支持了我们，嗯，你应该去查收一下邮箱了。这是一个激动人心的时刻。你可以在Facebook上找到《99%隐形》并参与有关节目的讨论。你可以在Twitter上@我（Roman Mars），也可以@节目账号（99PI），或者在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上找到我们。我们还在99PI.org上提供更多视觉设计故事和视频。Radiotopia。来自PRX。
you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你 本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。